you're going to meet somebody very very
special in my life somebody new somebody
shiny somebody who smells so good like
five months old good
hello honey
hello
[Applause]
meet baby monaco jeannie mai introduces
her five-month-old daughter for the
first time since welcoming her back in
january with husband jeezy fam there is
no way that i could sit here and just
tell you about the amazing magical
phenomenal human being that has entered
my life
so let me show you yeah jeannie gives
fans an inside look at the first few
months with her little one on her
youtube series hello honey the first
part of the video includes a montage
highlighting some of monaco's biggest
milestones
[Music]
look at me lifting up my neck
look daddy
wow
somebody's so strong
then monaco makes her debut as genie
brings her out on camera for the first
time
yeah
monaco
hi baby
hey baby
how are you but not without the help of
her mom mama mai
i could not i could not
get past these five months without mama
my
mama mine has watched monaco as i've
shot the real flown to different jobs
got sleep to look decent today and of
course the first time mom can't help but
gush over her baby girl jeannie says
she's loving all parts of motherhood
even the smelly ones we love watching tv
like this together i love when she
passed gas oh my goodness it's the
cutest thing she passed out like 10
times a day she's so much fun she loves
dancing yeah listen look it look you
look up right okay
it's exciting to just watch her change
every single day we see
a little bit more lashes growing out
she's got a beautiful head of hair
but before jeannie introduced monaco to
the world she got emotional admitting
that new mom anxiety is real i think
this is what i was going through the
last five months to be honest with you
it's such a weird combination between
being so excited about something
but
knowing that the world is a really mean
place sometimes but this isn't the first
time jeannie's been open about her
struggles after giving birth honestly it
was treacherous because
nobody told me that there's postpartum
anxiety i went home from my doctor's
like i was out and about i was happy
being a mom i was excited but i was
intensely worried it's so much so that
kevin you know i love sharing everything
on the gram you share everything yes
yeah but the day monica was born i got
freaked out i shut everything down we
were like no cameras no nothing because
i was so afraid of the internet and the
people and then what if someone says
something about her that i can't handle
and i'm not being genie jenkins the way
i should be you know and it's that
authenticity that makes genie shine so
brightly even though there's difficult
moments she told e.t becoming a mom has
changed her for the better now i'm
beyond grateful because i cannot believe
as every parent will tell you how much a
child changes your life and i like
myself better right i like myself better
as a mom cheers to mama genie and
hopefully more cute cameos from baby
monaco monica monica i love my monaco
monaco monaco i love you so so
dude
[Music]
you